Things you must bring if you plan to emigrate this 2 024,
your studies apostilled,
especially your apostilled studies.
If it is a baccalaureate
bring the last 4 notes you have plus the title.
If it's university toucas,
brings all the university's toucas history.
If it is 1 1 training in training,
2nd senior,
brings all the history also apostilled.
Why do I tell you
that you have to bring all this apostilled?
Because so
When you arrive,
you will be able to apply for homologation,
won't you?
And perhaps with the baccalaureate,
for example,
you can find 1 training center and host
to what it is eh,
the stay visa.
You have 59 days when you set foot on Spanish territory
to be able to apply for this stay visa
if you bring all the documentation
I'm telling you.
Economic income is also important,
or demonstrate your economic solvency,
health insurance,
etc.
hope you find these tips useful